avec nous la psychiatre Marie-Eve coton
ironiquement c'est le hasard il est en
Gaspésie ce soir justement bonsoir
docteur coton bonsoir Julie c'est
vraiment bouleversant d'entendre
monsieur Moreau qui était au premier
Loge qui est failli lui aussi se faire
heurter par ce chauffage qui nous
raconte les petits-enfants en pleurs on
ne comprend pas ce qui se passe dans la
tête de quelqu'un qui fait un juste
comme ça qu'est-ce que vous vous
comprenez
ben j'évite dans les premières heures
après un événement comme ça d'essayer de
donner un sens tout de suite parce que
je trouve que dans la précipitation on
fait beaucoup de spéculations qui ont un
risque à faire ça on a toujours beaucoup
plus d'informations qui nous permettent
de comprendre le sens de ça quand arrive
le procès où on a des évaluations etc ce
que j'essaie de communiquer quand ça
arrive c'est ce qu'on connaît de façon
générale sur les tueries de masse ce que
la recherche a
identifié adapte pour donner un sens à
tout ça et
j'essaie de mettre en évidence que bien
au-delà de la maladie mentale dont tout
le monde parle toujours en premier quand
des événements comme ça surviennent il y
a beaucoup d'autres facteurs sociaux qui
sont beaucoup plus selon la recherche
contributif
à ce genre d'événements donc j'essaie
dans ces moments-là de ramener ses
connaissances là pour qu'on apprenne
à comprendre
parce qu'effectivement vous le dites
toute la journée les policiers nous ont
parlé de santé mentale mais sans arrêt
en parlant des ressources est-ce qu'il y
en a assez les gens consultent plus etc
mais dans le fond on l'a pas le profil
et la couronne d'ailleurs lors de la
comparution a dit pour l'instant rien
nous permet de penser que un problème de
santé mentale derrière ça en fait on dit
il y a même pas eu de demandes la part
de la défense pour qu'il soit évolué cet
homme-là donc rien ne remet en doute son
attitude à comparer alors si c'est pas
un problème de santé mentale ça peut
être quoi qu'est-ce qui peut pousser
quelqu'un à commettre un acte aussi
extrême
parce que la recherche nous dit c'est
que s'il y a 22% des soirs de masque qui
ont un trouble de santé mentale il y a
d'autres facteurs plus importants
premièrement 96 à 98 % des soirs de
masse sont des hommes donc on parle
vraiment d'un geste qui qui spécifique
aux hommes donc ça c'est le facteur le
plus important ensuite 70% de ces
soirs-là sont isolés socialement donc
c'est pas des gens qui ont un réseau
élab solide sur lequel ils peuvent
s'appuyer quand la vie est difficile
donc ça devrait nous amener à parler
beaucoup plus d'exclusion sociale et
d'inclusion sociale
près de 50% ont été intimidés harcelés
dans leur vie dans leur enfant ce qui
fait qu'ils peuvent avoir à l'intérieur
d'eux des sentiments de vengeance du
ressentiment donc on devrait aussi
parler de lutte à l'intimidation dans
les écoles etc on parle jamais de ça
60% ont des troubles de d'alcool et de
drogue alors que c'est un domaine dans
lequel on a coupé dans les dernières
années les ressources de traitement pour
topsychomanie et alcoolisme alors je
trouve que les politiciens ratent
l'essentiel de ce qu'on connaît et que
leur façon de cibler uniquement la
maladie mentale elle est très
stigmatisante pour les gens qui ont des
troubles mentaux
parce que ils sont seulement
responsables à 22%, c'est une et la
Vasse majorité des gens qui ont des
troubles de santé mentale ne sont pas
violents pourtant dans les prix jugés on
les trouve de plus en plus violeurs la
population a plus de chances de craindre
la violence des gens qui ont des
maladies mentales aujourd'hui comme 1950
et je pense que il faut faire attention
particulièrement dans des moments comme
ça pour ne pas stigmatiser les personnes
qui ont des qui ont des troubles de
santé mentale c'est très curieux c'est
que il y a un mois et quelques semaines
il y avait ce drame à Laval un homme on
le connaît l'histoire là au volant d'un
autobus qui est foncé dans la garderie
qui a fait deux petites victimes qui a
fait beaucoup de blessés il y a quelque
chose qui se ressemble dans cette
histoire-là est-ce que c'est possible
est-ce que tu l'hypothèse qui pourrait
tenir la route de dire là c'est une
sorte de geste d'imitation est-ce que ça
peut arriver
c'est à dire que dans les suries de
masse le phénomène de contagion sociale
est connu on peut pas dire que cette
souris là à me cuit et le résultat d'une
contagion par exemple la tuerie de
lavage parce que souvent il y a pas une
seule cause à une tuerie puis on peut
pas comme ça établir un lien direct en
deux tueries mais on sait selon les
recherches qui ont été faites sur les
Tuileries de masse que à chaque 5 tuerie
il y en a une sixième qui survient qui
serait pas survenue si c'était pas un
phénomène pour lequel il y a de la
contagion sociale donc on sait que ce
phénomène-là existe il est moins
important que dans le cas du suicide
c'est-à-dire qu'on sait que quand il y a
de la médiatisation importante les
suicides de célébrité par exemple ça va
entraîner de la contagion c'est à dire
des suicides par imitation c'est encore
plus fort l'effet dans le cas des
suicides mais ça existe aussi dans le
cas des turines de masse donc c'est
quand même à connaître il y a des on
sait que les tueurs de masse la
recherche de notoriété c'est une des
causes possibles parce que
parfois ils ont fait des recherches sur
d'autres soirs de masse ils ont admiré
ils ont ils ont envie la tension
publique et médiatique que les gens ont
eu donc c'est ça qui a conduit à toutes
les principes de notoriété zéro on
essaie de réduire
la visibilité publique des tueurs et ça
c'est un autre élément qu'on connaît
cette contagion sociale là et la
recherche continuera certainement à je
comprends qu'on évacue pas l'hypothèse
on peut pas faire de lien immédiat mais
c'est possible il y a quelque chose qui
reste quand même vous vous êtes docteur
vous êtes psychiatre vous faites la
différence entre un trouble de
personnalité et une maladie mentale par
exemple nous on a tendance à tout mettre
dans le même sac mais on se dit quand
même le profil que vous nous avez dit le
c'est un homme qui peut être isolé
socialement qui peut avoir des problèmes
de consommation mais quand même c'est
pas tous les gens qui ont ces
facteurs-là qui pensent à l'acte qui
vont foncer dans des personnes âgées ou
des petits enfants docteur coton pour
arriver à faire sauf quand même avoir un
trouble vous appuyez peut-être pas ça de
la santé mentale mais il y a quand même
quelque chose qui fait une différence
entre une personne qui va faire ce geste
là et l'autre personne qui vient à peu
près les mêmes conditions et qu'il fera
jamais
absolument parce que les gens disent
souvent faut pas aller bien pour faire
ça je suis d'accord faut pas personne se
lève un matin en disant je ne vis
gratifiante je me sens accomplie je vais
poser ce genre de geste là c'est
assurément des gens qui sont en
souffrance qui sont en déséquilibre dans
leur vie qui font face à quelque chose
de difficile maintenant la nuance c'est
qu'on a pas besoin d'être malade pour
être malheureux c'est à dire que on peut
être malheureux parce que on a vécu des
choses difficiles être exclu socialement
c'est dur avoir subi du harcèlement de
du l'intimidation c'est difficile
vivre des séparations des aides pauvres
de pas avoir d'emploi c'est difficile et
tout ça s'accumule ça peut accumuler des
frustrations des blessures à l'intérieur
des individus et des passages à l'acte
mais ça n'en est pas pour autant une
maladie mentale c'est sûr que de la
détresse là-dedans c'est quelqu'un de
souffrant mais c'est des gens qui ont
besoin
d'aide mais ce n'est pas des gens qui
ont des maladies mentales au sens d'un
trou psychotique d'une maladie bipolaire
d'une dépression etc
c'est différent d'où l'importance d'en
parler justement pour ne pas créer
davantage de préjudice envers les gens
qui souffrent de problèmes de maladies
mentale mais racontent dans ce que si on
a assez bien un peu sur l'accusé dans
les faits mais on essaie toujours de
comprendre ce qui se passe parce que
c'est tellement révoltant docteur coton
merci encore pour vos lumières
aujourd'hui ça me fait plaisir merci